à lison cette proposition avec damien
contandriopoulos professeur à l'école
des sciences infirmières à l'université
de victoria en colombie-britannique
bonsoir bonsoir 6 milliards en quatre
ans pour la santé notamment le début de
la mise en oeuvre de régimes
d'assurance-médicaments nationale est-ce
que c'est suffisant ça dépend pour quoi
faire
le début de la mise en oeuvre c'est
certainement faisable on s'entend par
contre que le fonctionnement réel d'un
régime public d'assurance médicaments
c'est beaucoup plus que 6 milliards de
dollars par an c'est beaucoup plus que 6
milliards et donc ces mêmes 15 20 25
milliards selon différentes estimations
le domaine total de médicaments au
canada c'est de l'ordre de 28 milliards
de ça il ya environ 24 milliards de
dollars qui sont des médicaments
assurables de médicaments dont
l'efficacité a été prouvée des
médicaments qui sont prescrites ces
terrains là dessus à peu près 9
milliards sont payés par des assurances
privées 3 milliards et demi sont payés
directement la poche des contribuables
la balance c'est déjà des choses qui
sont payés par les gouvernements
provinciaux entre autres pour les
personnes de plus de 65 ans pour les
gens grande pauvreté etc
donc quand on parle de du gouvernement
fédéral qui viendraient implanter un
régime public donc de fait nationalisé
le domaine du médicament
on parle de dépenses de l'ordre de 12
milliards si le gouvernement fédéral
reprenait à son compte
exactement le régime actuel par contre
il est évident qu'il ya des économies
si on a un seul acheteur qui achètent
des médicaments pour 30 millions de
personnes
ça permet d'avoir des meilleurs prix
quelques milliards de dollars en achats
de gros plein doute et c'est là où il ya
une inconnue
de combien on pourrait qu est ce qu on
pourrait économiser exactement les
estimés varie 10% à 20% 30% mais c'est
de cet ordre là il y aurait aussi
probablement une légère augmentation du
volume de médicaments qui serait
consommée puisque certaines personnes
actuellement s'est restreinte donc aurez
accès mais quand on revient les
paramètres réaliste c'est quelque chose
de l'ordre de 10 milliards de leurs
parents qui seraient qui devraient être
investis par le gouvernement
je juste bien comprendre parce qu'il est
plusieurs à plusieurs chiffres
conseiller depuis tantôt on a commencé à
28 milliards pour le coût 24 milliards
assurables
si on faisait un plein universel dans
tout le canada se serait combien parce
que vous vous avez déjà pris part au
processus d'examen d'un rapport du
directeur parlementaire du budget c'est
en septembre 2010 et on parlait de plus
de 20 milliards par année 20 milliards
par année c'est donc l'ensemble de ce
que coûte à peu près le domaine du
médicament assurables mais là-dessus et
c'est ça qui est important de voir c'est
que les gouvernements sont déjà
largement impliqué ils payent déjà de
façon significative les médicaments on
pense par exemple au québec le régime
public d'assurance médicaments du québec
des dépenses qui sont déjà assumé par
les gouvernements et on est certain que
dans la création d'un régime fédéral y
aurait des ententes
fédérales-provinciales qui ferait en
sorte que les dépenses qui sont
actuellement prises en charge par le
provincial il c'est vrai dans toutes les
provinces cana serait articulé avec une
forme de transfert vers le fédéral donc
quand on regarde la partie du médicament
qui pour l'instant n'est pas payée par
les gouvernements c'est à peu près de 9
milliards de sur ans privé est à peu
près 3 milliards et quel type de
dépenses directement des consommateurs
qui paient au comptoir et ont cependant
qu'il y aurait des économies importantes
que la fureur soit le gouvernement oui
c'est certain il ya des économies des
pays l'ont déjà fait on pense à la
nouvelle zélande entre autres il ya eu
des économies très significative donc on
est certain que c'est moins de 12
milliards combien - a
difficile de faire une anticipation
précise et surtout on connaît pas
exactement à quelle date tout ça entrera
en vigueur
mais grosso modo on peut penser à
quelque chose de l'ordre de 10 milliards
plus ou moins par année de dépenses pour
le domaine du médicament
jose qui est important à mettre de
l'avant c'est que c'est pas des dépenses
additionnelles c'est vraiment un
transfert de ce que pour l'instant on
paye comme primat nos assureurs privés
vers quelque chose qui serait
probablement des textes versé au
gouvernement fédéral
ce serait une issue aussi je veux bien
comprendre lescure et hausses d'impôts
il y aurait certainement hausses
d'impôts d'un côté et mais de l'autre
côté il faut bien voir tous les
contribuables qui actuellement paye des
primes d'assurance pour être assurés
pour leurs médicaments pris une
assurance que vous payez généralement
sur votre chèque de paye parce que vous
êtes assurés par votre employeur
j'ai pris une assurance la disparaîtrait
l'un dans l'autre le consensus est que
pour le commun des mortels on paierait
moins cher pour le médicament qu'est-ce
qu'on paye actuellement au niveau
macroéconomique
c'est une bonne idée est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui est réaliste à
l'intérieur de l'envelope dont les
libéraux ont parlé d'un 6 milliards
étalés sur quatre ans on voit bien que
les chiffres balance pas similaire sur 4
1 c'est un engagement qui permet
probablement de travailler à mettre en
place les structures qui permettrait de
gérer un régime ouais c'est pas un
montant qui permet de faire fonctionner
le régime
non c'est ça ce serait que le début
comment réagir et les compagnies
pharmaceutiques en retour il ya deux
groupes d'acteurs qui vont être très
fâché à un les compagnies
pharmaceutiques pourquoi parce que si on
dit qu'on peut économiser sur le coût
des médicaments en achetant un gros faut
bien voir que sa réplique aussi pour les
compagnies pharmaceutiques de les vendre
moins cher ce qu'elle n'aime pas en
général et le deuxième groupe d'acteurs
ca les compagnies d'assurance privées
d'un coup se verrait sortie de leur
marché oui dans les deux cas c'est des
acteurs économiques puissants qu'ils
vont faire tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour
faire dérailler la machine ça va aller
du lobbying direct ça va aller à des
publicités puis on peut aussi voir les
compagnies pharmaceutiques actuellement
par exemple dans les discussions qu'a
eues avec le nouvelles règles
américaines des compagnies
pharmaceutiques faire planer une menace
de pénurie médicament était en robe
c'est probablement en partie des
pressions commerciales qui sont destinés
à faire réfléchir les canadiens sur leur
envie de négocier fermement avec
l'industrie comment se fait-il que par
habitant seuls les etats-unis la suisse
paie plus cher que nous pour les
médicaments d'ordonnancé parce qu'il ya
aucune forme de régulation
c'est aussi simple que ça tous les pays
développés vont avoir des structures qui
vont encadrer le prix auquel les
compagnies en droit de vendre leurs
médicaments
le canada le fait par exemple en
fonctionnant sur la moyenne dans le
panier de pays les pays vont utiliser
soit la moyenne des autres pays soit la
valeur thérapeutique soit une règle
interne mais donc vont fixer aux
compagnies un médicament vous pouvez pas
le vendre plus que tel montant et là les
états unis n'ont aucune forme de
régulation sur le prix si tu fais
agresser awad mark webber ce que le
marché pourra soutenir en termes de
paiement et ça donne lieu à des
pratiques commerciales qui sont sur le
plan humain assez grave car absolument
merci beaucoup damien contandriopoulos à
victoria ce soir merci pour cette
analyse
ça m'a fait très plaisir à voir